what's going on guys this is rob and
i've got some lego marvel
was searching all over the gameplay and
looking for different uh different
sources for really good marvel podcasts
because i was thinking maybe i can try
to get onto one maybe i can try to help
my channel grow and
gain more exposure by being on you know
another podcast somewhere
and the more i looked around the more i
saw that a lot of the podcasts that were
out there were
great big huge podcasts and they weren't
really like youtube correlated i mean
there were some there's there's like
comic book girl and stuff like that but
you know of course i sent her a message
and never got a reply but i imagine that
you know when you're that size in terms
of your youtube channel that
is really difficult to sift through all
the messages and reply to the ones that
you want to reply to and
you know to catch the ones where you
know they they want your attention or
something like that but
nonetheless you know i was thinking that
that why not start my own podcast
why not have my own podcast that i have
here on my youtube channel so
so here's what i'm thinking i'm thinking
that we take two videos a week we scale
it back and we do one video a week and
that'll be marvel requests monday
because
if i want to give up doing one video a
week it's not going to be the request
that you guys have i want to keep that
element of my channel in place and i
think it'd be really fun to uh to really
kind of
kind of have that going so i figure we
can keep marvel requests monday
and then every thursday we can do a
podcast i can upload a podcast
i don't know if that's something you
guys would be interested in but if it is
what i'd really like to do here is in
truth i'd like to keep the podcast
homegrown
meaning that i would like it to consist
of uh
some of my subscribers you guys and me
so i don't know if any of you guys are
interested in doing a podcast
i don't know if any of you guys are set
up for it i mean i've got a blue yeti
mic
and you know a boom boom arm and all
that kind of good stuff but
i don't have like a mixer or anything um
but
i imagine that if you guys are
interested we can work out the details
um
the one thing i do ask is that you do
have like a good quality microphone i
mean i'd hate to you know make it sound
like i'm talking to you over a cell
phone or something like that but
um nonetheless you know let me know if
that's something you guys would be
interested in seeing let me know if
that's something you all would be
interested in
and being a part of because i think it'd
be really really fun to just kind of
have
a general format discussion nothing in
particular nothing specific we're not
going to like
review movies every other weekend or
every other week or we're not going to
talk only about comic books it's really
just kind of like an open general format
kind of podcast i mean given that this
is a comic book channel i'm pretty sure
it'll be
really geared more towards comic books
than anything else but nonetheless
you know i really do think it'd be kind
of a fun thing i think it'd be kind of a
fun experience
so um you know let me know what you guys
think let me know what you guys want to
do
and uh yeah i will catch you guys later
peace